we got the final eight episodes coming
up oh my goodness I'm gonna cry I've
been a fan of the show for so long I
remember the very first episode so to
know that the end is near is pretty
incredible when you learn to AD was what
was your reaction I would like to play
dumb but you know it's pretty little
ours and it's insects it's absolutely no
one knows everyone's like oh I know who
it is and I was like you don't you
definitely don't as both a fan and a
star of the show were you happy with how
things wrap up absolutely there's just
been so many questions and now we're
getting those answers and it's just so
satisfying eight years of questions one
big season of answers did you get every
answer you need in yes I was so
satisfied as a fan I was I went up too
early and I was like thank you on behalf
of everybody thank you so much for this
now Lucy told us Aria goes on what she
called a dark path in these final
episodes what you have to say for your
character um you know she's here in the
Komen next week is the big one and we're
gonna find out how that all pans out for
Yvonne the Yobe saga can happen
you